uh full pun intended chairs are the
biggest issue
in the fat community if you have never
looked at a picture
of a restaurant on google maps to try
and figure out if the seating would be
accessible to your size if you've never
broken a chair in a public space
especially
if you've never had to second-guess
whether or not it was okay to sit down
in the chairs provided to you if you've
never had a panic attack at
school because you couldn't fit into the
damn chair desk situation then you don't
deal with fat phobia at the same level
that the rest of us do if you sat down
on a chair in the chair breaks which
if that happens
is the chair fatphobic the notion that
all chairs everywhere are supposed to be
built with the possibility in mind that
you are 200 pounds overweight is insane